[Music]
journalist Marika sporos has dubbed
Mikaela Peterson the queen of carnivore
and I think that's a great title I'm
certain that she spread more awareness
of the potential therapeutic benefits of
this diet than many of the rest of us
combined
her story is deeply inspiring and today
she will give us her thoughts on using
the carnivore diet to treat autoimmune
diseases hi everybody it's very very
cool to be here I've been looking
forward to it for a while and it's been
super fun to meet people I've only seen
on social media which is strange today
I'm gonna talk about specifically how to
use the carnivore diet to treat people
who are really really ill does anybody
here is anybody here really really ill
or was really really ill was okay that's
cool well I was really really really ill
this okay um oh we're gonna get we're
gonna get through that in like more
detail than anybody wants to know and
there's some there's some pretty intense
pictures that I'll go through really
quickly so you don't have to look at
them for too long but it was bad I was
diagnosed I wasn't diagnosed I started
showing symptoms of rheumatoid arthritis
when I was 2 so it hit really quickly
and I was walking funny as soon as I
started walking basically okay I'm gonna
get started that's an old picture of me
but I was already carnivore that's last
year that's my daughter
so I'm Michaela Peterson mother blogger
I managed my dad and I was formerly
dying but I'm not anymore
so I went over this a bit but I used to
be really sick and I want to talk to
people who aren't just using the
carnivore diet to get like hotter but
but to get like healthier
so that's autoimmune to specifically
autoimmune disorders and mood disorders
but also you know fatigue skin problems
like a crack II jaw like whatever
okay so Age 2 I had symptoms of
rheumatoid arthritis so I was just
walking funny my parents used to put me
on their shoulders and when they put me
down I cried and it was like cried and
sat down so something was going on with
my hips as early as Age 2 when I was 7 I
was diagnosed with arthritis I had 35
joints that they could tell were
actively inflamed I had most of them
that year injected with cortisone so
that was the first surgery like they put
kids under on under general to do things
like cortisone shots so that was age
seven age eight I was the first kid in
Canada to put on be put on Enbrel so I
was taking methotrexate naproxen and
brawl which is a biologic drug
methotrexate is pretty intense too that
was age eight age nine I started
exhibiting more symptoms of depression
and anxiety with OCD tendencies that had
started around grade one but by the time
I was in grade five it was severe enough
for me to be medicated so I was put on
an SSRI when I was 10 at 14 I started
getting tired and itchy so that happened
just over a winter and it was like
mosquitoes everywhere but there was no
sign of anything and I was sleeping a
lot but was also staying up late and it
was really hard to tell if it was me
being lazy or if it was fatigue and I
battled with that and with my parents
for the next five years with the fatigue
because it's hard to tell when people
with like invisible problems are sick or
whether or not they're just being lazy
and it's hard for them to tell - and I
can tell you like if you don't want to
get out of bed in the morning
something's wrong it's not you being
lazy age 17 hip replacement so I was
told at 16 that I would need a hip
replacement before the age of 30 because
of the state my hip was in and in the
next six months it got so much worse
that I needed a hip replacement then so
that's my healing picture it was intense
that's my hip replacement which has
actually done really well the same year
I needed an ankle replacement so after I
got my hipped on my ankle cartilage just
disappeared so that's the left side just
like bone on bone that was a terrible
year
that's the ankle replacement so that was
17 so things were not improving even
though I was on Umbrella methotrexate at
this point sip relax an oxycontin for an
entire year because of that pain so I
went to university at 19 because I
needed to take an extra year of
University because of all the school I
messed which made me really angry but I
went to University and then things went
downhill like really quickly because my
diet went from like healthy whole grains
but meat and like we ate organic and
like my mum was trying to be healthy -
surviving off of noodles and things God
things things got really bad in
university I gained weight my mood my
mood was just awful I went completely
nuts I kept trying to fix my
antidepressants and try and like an SNRI
which went really badly I went up on
wellbutrin high enough that it gave me a
seizure it was a it was a rough year
so then I was like okay I can I can
tolerate this I'm slowly gaining weight
but like I can handle this and then it
started to hit my skin so I'm gonna
really go through fast go through some
skin pictures so you can see what I was
dealing with but it started hitting my
skin and doctors were telling me you
know you're doing it yourself stop
because I kept going and saying my skin
is like dying what's happening and
they're like well stop scratching I was
like
it's like you don't understand so I'm in
doctors offices I'm like crying and and
they're like well you're crazy okay okay
this isn't working out for me so this is
what started to happen these are these
are some not fun pictures that's me
looking puffy and really unimpressed
with life so when I was 22 and like my
prefrontal cortex had mostly grown in I
started researching because I realized
like how sick I actually was when you're
a kid you kind of just like go along
with things you don't realize was like
oh arthritis that seems like something
that's embarrassing but whatever but at
22 I was like oh this is actually
killing me so I started researching and
I read I started with a skin problem
because I was like okay I'm gonna have
depression for life I'm gonna have
arthritis for life but I really don't
want my skin to look like that so it was
like a vanity thing and I was like I
can't handle all these symptoms plus the
skin sentence so I went through like
hundreds of papers on skin disorders and
eventually after a really long time I
came across a celiac rash which is a
gluten caused rash that causes itchy
blistering and I had never equated these
skin problems with the itching I had
started experiencing when I was 14 so I
got that and then I went like down the
road into gluten and realized that that
is really not good for your guy just for
everybody but specifically for people
with the celiac gene and I had my genes
done and I have the celiac gene so I cut
out gluten anyway I'm getting ahead of
myself
these are some of my met and medications
some of them are doubled up but it was
like adderall what's on here adderall
Tylenol three dapsone that's an
antibiotic that was for the rash
citalopram was for mood Val cycle of
beer that's cold sores I had city Rosine
just because I was allergic to
everything and Braille was for arthritis
adverse for asthma sees now that's birth
control I don't even know what Tavis
separate Ronin he is vyvanse was
like a something to take along with the
adderall to keep me awake yeah it was a
lot so mm-hmm no those are gone I
brought like a bag back to them back to
the pharmacy
okay so 2015 I realized the gluten-free
wasn't a fad and then over that that
didn't really make much of a difference
honestly getting rid of gluten so in
September I went on an elimination diet
that I kind of came up with myself and
it was just meat root vegetables and
rice because I thought those seemed like
things nobody's allergic to I kind of
just tried to cut out allergens and I
did it for a week and nothing changed
and I was I didn't realize this but I
was getting cravings at that point and I
made gluten-free dairy-free sugar-free
banana almond flour muffins I was like
that's healthy and I just like ate you
know like five of them that night and I
woke up the morning my wrists were kind
of sore and I was like ah maybe there's
something to this and then I had like
four more muffins because like sore
wrists whatever the muffins were good
and and and then the next day I was in
the grocery store shopping and my knees
locked up and I spent the next two and a
half days in bed and that never happened
with my arthritis like I didn't really
have bad flare-ups in my knees um and so
I thought oh my god like maybe there's
something to this so I went back to the
original elimination diet and I lost
three pant sizes that month and five
pounds and I thought well that doesn't
really make any sense and it turned out
the reason I could never get abs was
because I was just permanently bloated
which I hadn't even known was a thing so
I went through this for a number of
years on the low-carb diet
I cut out rice because I realized that
bothered me but I was on something that
was like apples greens root vegetables
but not potatoes meat and I was doing
really really well on that and
I stopped all my medication and I
stopped my antidepressants in November
and people in Canada know it's really
dark in November and if you're depressed
that's not when you stop medication but
I could I could tell what the depression
was gone thank you
when you take antidepressants you still
know it's there and it lifted and it's
like whoa I gotta get my dad on this
because he has he has the same
depression I have so he went on it and
then we tried to reintroduce foods and
did it just terribly like I said earlier
you know it was like might as well go
out with a bang if I can't eat you know
anything sugar you know anything so I
need a whole pile of it and then I
started experiencing these horriffic
reactions and I went to doctors and I
was saying man I think I'm allergic to
soy I think I'm allergic to almonds like
I think I'm allergic to to sugar and
they're going well it's not showing up
on the skin test and I was like it's not
an IgE allergy like it's something else
something's happening like do you look
into you know other types of antibodies
or inflammatory reactions no those
aren't real allergies I was like I every
introduced a whole bunch of food my
arthritis is back my skin is breaking
out I have body odor my gums are
bleeding my face is puffy and I'm on the
verge of hallucinating and nothing is
happening like you could see something
happening so I I went to an immunologist
the last time February 2016 and then I
just I just stopped so I gave up with
the food introductions but I stuck with
this low carb diet and everything was
going great and then I got pregnant and
then all my symptoms came back which was
really scary and really frustrating
because when they leave and then they
come back it's just and I'm sure a lot
of people know about that it is so scary
so they came back and I didn't know what
to do for about a year and I came across
like I knew meat didn't bother me and at
that point I was eating meat and lettuce
and pepper and salt and apple cider
vinegar and olive oil so as really I was
like the lettuce is keeping my vitamins
alive like I need to keep this and I
came across Shaun Baker on Joe Rogan and
he was saying oh I've been doing this
for two years I was like well he's big
and strong and looks healthy like okay
so that that night I cut everything out
and I had transition symptoms just from
dropping like lettuce olive oil and was
there some turmeric there too and I
still went through transition symptoms
I've been in ketosis for three years so
it had nothing to do with ketosis it was
something else and but about a week
later the itching stopped and the
Arthritis went away and my digestion was
just a disaster
and I was like well I guess I ought to
trade off right I don't want the itching
and the arthritis my depression lifted
in about six weeks I wasn't happy but I
wasn't depressed and that was good
my mum hopped on board really quickly in
January so he want to give it a shot
just like sure she's been like
vegetarian like she's done everything so
she's very open she started that and
then I like worked at my dad because he
worked in work because he was literally
just eating meat and greens and he was
waking up with horrible anxiety and he
was saying this isn't working I was like
just drop the greens just drop the
greens like every day until April and
eventually he was home and I could like
corner him and his version is not is not
true
so he dropped the Greenes and he said
three days later the horrible do me
feeling in the morning went away three
days so that's my mom and this is her on
the carnivore diet she let me take this
picture she knows it's here
she's 57 yeah and that is everything she
was suffering from she cut out blue
wheat a long time ago we were all like
mom and her wheat allergy but uh that's
what she had and she's good now she's
happy she's still doing meat it's been a
year it's dad um he is 57 and he looks
great
his has been a little bit more difficult
to get under control with mood problems
but he's I mean he had a whole bunch of
problems he was sleeping all the time
too I he NE never naps now he's just go
right he's done what like a hundred and
eighty tours this year like he's got
unlimited energy so what do you do if
you've restricted your diet or you've
tried carnivore diet and it still isn't
working well they like the popularized
carnivore diet right now is animal
products and dairy was one of the
biggest triggers for my autoimmune
disorder and my mood disorder so if
you've tried carnivore and you haven't
tried just eating beef then that's the
next step and hopefully people can try
carnivore and do eggs and do some dairy
and still feel awesome and that's great
but if you're in the category of people
who are ridiculously sensitive for some
for some reason you have to really
buckle down so I only eat beef and lamb
I can do ruminant animals I'm eating
salt and that's it I don't really go out
to eat like I went out in Florida and I
was very you know very annoying at the
restaurant
like scrub the grill I'm allergic to
everything what are the allergies and I
was just like wow
soy dairy gluten sugar sulfates because
I know that covers most things you like
sprinkle on a steak but the girl wasn't
as
clean as it should have been and I had a
you know minor for me but I still
reacted to the grill so I don't really
eat out so if you're in the category of
people and you're still having
autoimmune symptoms you like really
gotta buckle down my depressions
triggered pretty easily too and so is my
dad's yeah one of the things I wanted to
talk to you and I'm sure people are
aware of that here but you're taught by
the medical community in particular but
by everyone really to stop listening to
your body so if something's wrong you go
hey like you know this feels funny and
they go oh everybody has that like okay
I'll put that in the section of like
ignore and these symptoms like they may
grow and grow and they're like oh these
little tiny problems but they're normal
everyone has that everyone gives a slump
at three it's the 3 p.m. slump so listen
to your body that took me years to
figure out because I was going on you
know I ate that and I feel kind of heavy
but that's fine and so you have to get
past that really start paying attention
to your body if you're sensitive go a
hundred percent go like all the way beef
and salt and at least give that a shot
for like a solid six weeks solid six
weeks it might take longer than that for
me it was about six weeks but it
improved after five months and then it
approved again after ten months so it
takes a while which isn't surprising if
you're trying to deal with an uncurable
illness and I suppose like most people
here are probably eating meat but these
are some of the things you're gonna have
to deal with it is hard but it's not as
hard as being sick for your entire life
like nothing is that hard so it's worth
a try and then yeah these are just ways
to succeed get the food you can't eat
out of your house because when the
cravings hit they hit hard and you'll
binge eat so and get it out of the house
try and make sure like if you're at with
roommate
I don't know man like when I first
started cutting food out I was on 40
milligrams of Aperol a day which just
destroys your appetite so I was like oh
yeah I can survive off of you know
tasteless mush because everything is
tasteless mush right now so when I went
low-carb it was easier to get off of
sugar that way I don't recommend taking
adderall in order to get over the sugar
cravings but they are hard so but they
do last they just drop off at some point
yeah so you can get your life back I got
my life back I got a life that I didn't
know existed I had lost hope at 14 my
arthritis had been put into a medical
remission when I was in grade six and I
thought I was one of the people that was
going to grow out of it and at 14 the
doctor was like oh your elbows inflamed
and it just like wrecked me for about a
month and I decided okay I'm not gonna
have any hope anymore because you can
just be crushed that way so yeah this is
oh my god I'm gonna like pull a Jordan
Peterson and cry go ahead okay it's over
it's over it's gone okay anyway it's
still a process I'm still dealing with
like I'm not really I'm not dealing with
anything like really compared to what I
was dealing with before but I am trying
to figure out how to make myself less
sensitive and my dad because we're still
very sensitive so I do think there are
underlying problems but this has
completely changed my life
and it's totally worth it and I'm
absolutely never going back so yeah
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]